the actual graph is zero okay we have a
name for that we call it an intercept
when they're the first derivative is
zero what do you call that first series
zero that's a that's a stationary point
it might be a turning point but it might
not be so station now and if you think
you know the answer this just hold on
for a second so we won't think about it
together when the second derivative is
zero what would that mean what would it
signify now I'm going to give you a name
for it in a second but I want to try and
illustrate the idea for you first let's
go back to that graph okay hmm this time
I've put pluses and minuses on to
indicate gradient okay this time I'm
going to put them on to indicate
concavity okay so for this part of X
cubed plus X I'm concave down okay and
then over this side I'm concave up now
how would you describe the contaminate
this point well I do go from negative to
positive and the thing between negative
positive is 0 how could we check that
out or you remember we drew on the
second derivative right this is y and
this is the second derivative and sure
enough at the origin the second
derivative is zero okay so what does
that mean it's not concave down and it's
not concave up it well if you had a lens
right you'd say it's concave or it's
convex what would you say if it looked
like this
it has the concavity right actually in
terms of life it's not gonna do any
lensing to it at all event so therefore
at this position here we would say
number one it has no contaminants okay
it's not concave up it's not concave
down but we can do they don't one of
them okay
can you narrow why don't we call it
stationary what a stationary have to do
anything
yeah so it's a it's a geometric
description okay it tells you about the
shape now here how would I describe this
shape well we call this a point of
inflection
what is inflection mainland we kind of
word right you can you can spell it with
a CT if you like but more commonly I see
it with Annette I didn't think of a
matter which way you spelt it but um
I've always gonna always spell it if you
read enough that's textbooks you made CT
invention over okay so you see what's
happening right can you imagine it kind
of like a on a bendy rule ah okay and
you're flexing it back and forth and
this is the place where it flexes from
one direction to another so it's kind of
that's why this inflection idea comes
strong okay so important inflection or
if you like okay it's pretty terrible
how do you go about fighting quite an
inflection okay well the most obvious
answer is you do this okay you let the
second derivative equal to zero okay and
that's fine most of the time that will
work